[Music]
this is a story about a puzzle called
kryptos
and one woman who spent almost two
decades trying to solve it
in the heart of the cia headquarters
lies a mystery
okay probably more than one mystery but
this one is weird because it's meant to
be solved it's a sculpture containing an
encoded message that's a challenge to
the cia employees but for 30 years no
one has been able to figure out what it
says
if anyone's got a shot it's a lanka
dunin i mean just listen to her when my
friends and family ask me what i want
for christmas i tell them to get several
puzzles mix all the pieces together and
then just give me a bag of pieces
i enjoy seeing order come out of chaos
when alanka's not solving jigsaw puzzles
she's cracking codes and she's good at
it
the da vinci code's author even named a
character after her nola k
i mean it's an anagram but you know
that's the kind of thing puzzle people
do
[Music]
one day alanka ran into a code that
finally stumped her
i first heard about kryptos i think in
late 2000.
it is about 12 feet tall and 20 feet
long it has thousands of characters
carved into it
kryptos has four codes in it three of
the four have been solved
the fourth has not been solved and it is
considered to be one of the most famous
unsolved codes in the world
here we are going on 30 years and it
still hasn't been cracked
alanka and crypt analysts around the
world have tried every technique in the
book polyalphabetic substitution
transposition playfair binary morse but
the fourth code only 97 characters long
it doesn't give an inch it just sits
there right in front of us
unsolved
so it raises a question of why
why is it that this artist jim sanborn
who had never created a code before in
his entire life
how could he have designed something
that has stumped the entire code
breaking world
[Music]
welcome to the island of jim sanborn
he is the artist who made kryptos and
he's the only person on earth who knows
the solution the code itself is in safe
deposit box that's pretty much where it
stays
in the late 1980s the cia was required
that they have a sculpture
i was ultimately selected to do the work
on the exterior of the building so i
chose to do a piece using encoded text
through this copper screen i cut with
jigsaws by hand almost 2 000 letters
and people have been contacting me
continuously daily for 30 years
about it
we have sushi we have drinks we have
chips
there is actually a kryptos group that
meets every year or so to do everything
humanly possible to get me to give them
a clue to kryptos
our kryptos community is made up of
people all around the world we have
thousands of people that are interested
in kryptos and
either cracking it or helping to see it
cracked some of them are professional
code breakers
some of them are students
often someone will just come in and toss
out an idea and then there will be some
brainstorming the topography has has
changed has anything
changed in terms of the solutions of
kryptos because of the changes that's a
that's a trap
question
often it's just a case of everyone just
wants to listen to every single thing
that jim might say about kryptos because
there's that hope that he will drop that
clue that little hint
that'll help so if one invested a lot of
time and the environment around kryptos
that would be kind of silly
i still have to be very vigilant and
extremely poker faced when everybody
wants to know what it says but i've
gotten after 30 years fairly good at
making it so that i don't flinch or
offer them a tell
and so far so good
[Music]
it's been 30 years since kryptos was
unveiled at the cia
and still
people are working to crack that fourth
code every single day
i think every artwork strives to hold
your attention for as long as possible
but if it's an artwork that contains
something that keeps your attention for
even 10 minutes much less 30 years
i get a great sense of satisfaction from
that
it's become part of many many people's
lives and i think that's the most
important part
people have asked me if i want to be the
one that solves kryptos and it doesn't
have to be me i want to see it solved
and if i can help by sharing as much
information as i know that's as good to
me as having actually cracked the code
[Music]
if i had to place a bet kryptos
yes kryptos will be solved i couldn't
tell you when
but it's a real code it's a real cipher
it's solvable
[Music]
you